>> IT WAS LIKE SEARS ALL THE
WAY.
HAVE YOU NOTICED HOW LOW THE
AIRLINE IS.
>> PATRICK.
MAY I TALK WITH YOU IN MY
OFFICE?
>> YOU HAVE BEEN CAUGHT TALKING
ABOUT YOUR BOSS AGAIN.
IF ONLY YOU CAN HIDE SOMEWHERE.
NOW YOU CAN.
INSIDE YOUR SHIRT.
♪♪♪
THE TURTLE SHIRT.
TURTLE SHIRTS ARE MADE BY SUITS,
THE SAME MATERIALS FROM WHICH A
TURTLE'S SHELL IS MADE.
THEY OFFER AN AMAZING PLACE TO
WAIT OUT UNWANTED AND
EMBARRASSING SITUATIONS.
>> WHO ARE YOU?
>> HERE YOU GO.
>> YOU HAVE MET MY WIFE?
>> I HAVEN'T.
CAN I JUST SAY YOUR HAIR IS SO
PRETTY THAT IT KIND OF LOOKS
FAKE.
>> SASHA WORKS WITH ORANGUTANS
AND ONE OF THEM TOOK HER SCALP
OFF.
>> THE TOP OF HER HEAD IS
COMPLETELY FAKE.
♪♪♪
>> IT'S LIKE HAVING A PERSONAL
PANIC ROOM ON YOUR BACK.
>> WHO ARE WANTS TO SEE A
PICTURE OF MY NEW BABY.
>> I'D LOVE TO.
THIS IS A PENIS.
THIS PICTURE IS A PENIS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S NOT MY BABY.
>> WAS THAT YOUR PENIS?
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
I DOUBT IT.
♪♪♪
>> AVAILABLE ONLY AT LORD AND
TAYLOR.